vom leopard und ins dirk laut meine
damen und herren herzlich kommen zu
einem neuen video ich habe ich auf
instagram um einsendung gebeten für ein
neues video und eine zuschauerin namens
bohnen bianca hat mir gesagt hey du
könntest mal auf tour at reagieren ein
paar von euch wenn es bestimmte und sich
das motto red schon wissen worum es geht
für alle anderen will ich einen kurzen
einstieg geben erst mal worum geht es in
dem heutigen video ich werde in dem
heutigen video auf den kanal gewitter im
kopf reagieren dass ein kanal der von
zwei jungs namens jan und tim betrieben
wird und jan ist quasi der der
mittelpunkt dieses kanals steht denn jan
hat zu red ganz kurz gefasst was ist
tourette ich will gar nicht so seien die
medizinischen details gehen aber
tourette ist eine erkrankung des
nervensystems die vor allem deswegen
sehr bekannt ist weil sie für
außenstehende vielleicht merkwürdig
wirkende spontane zuckungen im körper
oder auch ausrufe die manchmal auf
beleidigungen aus dem nicht sein können
verursacht genau an dieser jan dem
tourette hat war in einem galileo
beitrag und das über diesen gallego
beitrag über tourette sehr bekannt
geworden hat jetzt einen eigenen
youtube-kanal aufgemacht der
geisteskrank abgeht richtig popstar für
ich finde es echt gute arbeit ich werde
heute ein paar videos zu jahren an schon
angefangen mit dem galileo beitrag mit
dem er zuerst bekannt wurde dann auch
ein paar videos von seinem eigenen kanal
und ich würde sagen wir legen direkt
bloß bei denen sich die symptomatik vom
am tourette-syndrom so verschlimmert hat
das ist natürlich schwieriger geworden
eine ausbildung zu finden die mir auch
spaß macht muss er leider auch schon
aufgrund dessen von meinem beenden das
hier ist jan wir zuerst im galileo
beitrag der breiteren masse bekannt
wurde ich muss auch kurz vorneweg eine
sache sagen und das gleich mal
klarzustellen das thema krankheit
beziehungsweise behinderung ist ein sehr
sensibles thema und man muss natürlich
sehr vorsichtig sein wenn man damit
umgeht oder auch ein video darüber macht
jetzt ist es aber so dass ich schon ein
paar videos von ihnen gesehen habe und
jan selbst pflegt einen sehr humorvollen
umgang mit seinem tourette er hat seinem
tourette seiner erkrankung sogar namen
gegeben
die heißt gisela und ich finde es echt
sehr verwundert weil wir ja nun sein
umfeld mit seiner erkrankung umgehen
weil mit tourette erkrankung gerade in
der ausprägung wie an sie hat natürlich
bedeutet dass man sich prinzipiell erst
mal anders verhält im alltag als
menschen und umwelt erkranken das machen
und das kann wenn man damit keinen guten
umgang pflegen natürlich ein problem
seien aber jan ist ihr umgang mit seiner
krankheit mega locker und ich glaube den
jahren selbst sagt dass ein humorvoller
immer mit dieser krankheit die beste art
und weise ist dann können wir das in
dieser reaktion auch machen da kann ich
es irgendwo
verstehen wenn ich halt nix habe die
eventuell patienten gefährdet sind dass
ich dann diesen beruf nicht machen kann
dein gewicht stärkt die falschen leute
so äußert sich diese tourette erkrankung
bei janis es längst nicht so dass alle
leute die tourette haben auch so
beleidigungen raushauen oder dass sie
auch so stark getrickst haben wie er ich
habe zum beispiel selbst auch ein freund
der tourette hat tatsächlich aber bei
dem ist es nicht so krass ausgeprägte
soll sie sich dann daran dass er so eine
gewisse art von kopfbewegung hat die
immer wieder macht also er zog mit
seinem kopf wenn so eine gewisse
richtung und das ist quasi alles was too
red bei macht das wollte ich nur am
rande sagen das ist in ganz vielen
verschiedenen formen ausprägung und
stärken gibt und dass das nicht immer
zwingend so aussehen ist jan tut schon
alles um vorzubeugen
trotzdem im vorstellungsgespräch zählt
nun mal der erste eindruck da habt ihr
das schon wieder gesehen leute achtet
braucht den gesichtsausdruck von ihm und
von seinem freund wohl diesen spruch
raus aus ähnlichen fall mein penis
geklaut ich muss es an der stelle direkt
ist noch mal raus und ich finde das
richtig krass wie die damit umgehen ich
meine ich kann das selbst nicht so gut
einschätzen aber ich glaube es gehört
viel kraft dazu dass man so einen punkt
hin kommt wo man so einen lockeren
umgang mit dieser krankheit hat wie jan
den hat und wie sein umfeld das hat ja
und ganz nebenbei ist er jetzt auch noch
mega erfolgreiche youtuber also proxy an
ihrem bruder der personalleiter in dem
ich gegenüber saß er hat gespielt dann
habe ich den herren zurück an gespielt
und auch noch gerufen ist die wander
etwa interessanter als pommes
[Gelächter]
ist aber schon krass was da teilweise
auch für so herr groß rauskommen klar
ist natürlich dass ja nicht mit absicht
macht aber man ist als außenstehender
betrachtet und quasi ohne wissen über
seine situation oder seine krankheit so
ein spruch hört der sitzt schon
ordentlich gekümmert
warst du schon immer so hässlich also
man sieht es da wirklich leute seine
mutter nimmt es wirklich mit dem lächeln
und man kann es nicht oft genug sagen ob
man von außen drauf schaut echt richtig
respekt für den umgang mit der krankheit
also hier ist stamp ihn ausdrücklich
erlaubt als vergleich konzentrieren sich
darauf und ok hier ist ja jetzt bei der
therapeutin die ihm quasi bei dem umgang
mit seiner krankheit hilft oder
vielleicht auch ein bisschen ihm hilft
an der krankheit selbst zu arbeiten und
sie stellt ihm ein stempel den achten
wir darauf selbstmord
er wird halt auch erstmal die
therapeutin gestempelt das ist dann so
[Gelächter]
sagt es noch ein letztes mal leute ich
habe schon ein paar mal gesagt aber ich
will es noch mal sagen damit sich kein
moralapostel verpflichtet fühlt dieses
video falsch zu verstehen und mich
irgendwie eine kommentaren an zu machen
sondern eher krank wissen sehr sensibles
thema wie gesagt da muss man sehr
aufpassen mit damit umgeht aber jan
selbst und seine familie leben quasi den
humorvollen umgang vor und sagen damit
quasi von sich aus hätte es für uns okay
wenn man damit humorvoll umgeht und wir
finden man sollte damit umgehen und dann
ist es glaube ich auch okay dass man als
außenstehender so eine sache mit humor
begegnen so lange dass auch mit respekt
geschieht das war soweit der galileo
beitrag mit dem jahren bekannt wurde
aber es gibt auch noch einige diesen auf
seinem kanal hier zum beispiel ein video
was ich selbst auch schon gesehen habe
leben mit tourette autofahren in diesem
video sieht man wie er hinten im auto
sitzen quasi rumgefahren wird von einem
freund oder ein familienmitglied und er
redet parallel darüber wie das so ist
mit dem auto fahren ob er selbst auto
fahren darf
ob er auto fährt und dann redet ja auch
so darüber wie er seinen alltag
bewältigt und wie ihr herum kommt und
die antwort auf diese richtig geld
das ist jetzt auch nicht so tragisch ich
rege mit dem unsichtbaren wohnmobilen
er wird ihr quasi gefragt wie er so sein
alltägliches leben und dann genau in dem
moment kitcars ibis zu retten dann kommt
zum touristik und ja dass er seinen
alltag mit mit dem unsichtbaren
wohnmobil regelt das ist
und so tragisch ich rege mit dem
unsichtbaren wohnmobilen auch wenn seine
stimme auch selbst überlassen musste als
man muss sagen ist als außenstehender
haben sie recht unterhaltsam welche
dinge seien tourette quasi sagt wenn er
so ein ticker er regelt die dinge des
alltags mit seinem unsichtbaren boden
mobil megageil dann gibt es hier noch
ein video und zwar tourette im zoo
da schauen wir auch mal kurz rein ja
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
videos wo der langsam machen mal wieder
zeit
heute machen wir einen kleinen ausflug
gemeinsam mit dem tourette-syndrom
natürlich und zwar in den kölner zoo
hier geht dann also ich glaube da
könnten auch ganz überraschende reaktion
auf die tiere bei rauskommen mir ist gar
noch eine sache eingefahren zu dem thema
das stand auch unter dem video wo man
auf eine reaktion von oma auf ihn
reagiert hat mir schon zum kommentar
unter denen ich ziemlich gut fahne und
zwar der kommentar gesagt dass der
entscheidende punkt ist dass man
miteinander über die krankheit lacht und
nicht man selbst als nicht erkrankter
über den erkrankten nacht das eine ist
okay das andere ist nicht okay machen
wir einen kleinen ausflug wenn man sie
mit dem zentrum natürlich und zwar in
den kölner zoo und wir fanden dass man
sich auch mit unserem t shirt er hat
versteckt seine krankheit nicht hat
einen sehr offenen umgang damit da steht
drauf keine panik ist nur tourette
[Musik]
man muss man sagen auch noch mal respekt
an ich glaube es ist auch keine ganz
gewöhnliche sache wenn man als mensch
der toiletten dieser ausprägung hat
einfach eine große menschenmenge
reingeht zum beispiel im zoo weil man
einfach riskiert dass leute ein
missverstehen also dass leute denken
dass die wörter die man sagt böse
gemeint sind oder absichtlich rauskommen
und ja ich glaube viele dinge die für
uns so selbstverständlich sind zum
beispiel in der einkaufsstraße gehen
oder den zoo gehen können wenn man
tourette schon zu einer stresssituation
werden vom leoparden den stil geklaut
[Gelächter]
ihr alter giraffe komplett geröstet
[Musik]
vom leoparden in stil geklaut
die ganze giraffen ich bin eine schwule
giraffe jetzt sind sie im zug weiterging
sind nicht über den giraffen sondern im
neuen gehege
das ist ein clip ist gerade noch eine
sache eingefallen ich auch noch sagen
wollte ich glaube das entscheidende ist
dass man bei solchen themen durch einen
erkrankungen oder behinderungen die
leute die die krankheit haben selbst
entscheiden lässt wie damit umgegangen
wird also wenn erst sagen wir der effekt
damit zum mega ernsten umgang und kann
da überhaupt keinen spaß darüber machen
dann besser falsche außenstehende nicht
davon betroffen ist damit mit humor
umzusehen also ich glaube es wichtig
dass man die leute die die krankheit
selbst haben entscheiden lässt wie damit
umgegangen werden sollte ja er hätte
jetzt direkt in schwindel aufgedeckt ist
natürlich auch klebestifte das richtig
so wir haben uns meine stelle ecke
ausgesucht um ein paar fragen zu
beantworten denn machen jetzt rogan
legende egal was kommt zu diesem video
noch sagen ich finde es bei diesem video
wichtig dass ich nicht nur mir die ganze
zeit den arsch ab gelacht habe deswegen
war der anteil an lacher in diesem video
ein bisschen geringer als sonst
vielleicht sondern auch das ein bisschen
auf das thema behinderung und die leute
damit umgehen eingehe und bewusstsein
dafür schaffen dass leute mit
behinderung ein bisschen schwerer haben
im alltag als wir alle die keine haben
und ja leute das einzige was jetzt noch
sagen kann ist abonniert auf jeden fall
ganz kanal gewitter im kopf ist der
erste link in der beschreibung steht er
ihm ein vorgeschlagenes video ab und
schreibt gern mal die kommentare was ihr
gedacht hat als er zum allerersten mal
janz kanal gesehen habt falls ihre
forschung gesehen hat oder was ihr bei
diesem video gedacht habt dann können
wir gerne den kommentaren bisschen über
das thema diskutieren das war weit von
mir macht's gut